to battle rising hospitalizations one  reno hospital is now rebuilding a  temporary medical facility look at this  officials built a similar one just  earlier this year there's both a tent  and an alternative care site inside the  parking garage  staff can outfit another level of that  garage to fit an additional  700 patients but health care workers  hope those beds  never have to be filled we're looking at  that daily  and so we are preparing this that  if it needs to go live then we're ready  to go live for now that structure are  only being used for patients  suspected of having respiratory  illnesses to be screened for covet 19.